Where does the information
and dreams come from?
And I think what the w w where it comes
from is that we watch the patterns that
everyone acts out.
We've watched that forever and we've got
some representations of those patterns.
That's part of our cultural history.
That's what's embedded in stories,
in fictional accounts of,
of the story between good and evil,
the bad guy and the good
guy and the romance,
you know,
these are,
these are canonical patterns of being
for people in and they deeply affect us
because they represent what it is
that we will act out in the world.
And then we fleshed that out with the
individual information we have about
ourselves and other people.
And so it's like there's a,
there's a,
there's waves of a behavioral patterns
that manifest themselves in the crowd
across time that great dramas are
played on the crowd across time.
And the artists watched that and,
and they get intimations of what that is
and they write it down and they tell us
and then we're a little
clearer about what we're up to.
No.
Like a great dramatists like Shakespeare
let's say is we know that what he wrote
is fiction and then we say,
well fiction isn't true.
But then you think,
well wait a minute.
Maybe it's true.
Like numbers are true.
You know,
numbers are an abstraction
from the underlying reality,
but no one in their right mind would
really think numbers aren't true.
You could even make a case that the
numbers are more real than the things that
they represent,
right?
Cause the obstruction
is so insanely powerful.
Once you have mathematics,
you're just deadly.
You can move the world with mathematics.
And so it's not obvious that the
abstraction is less real than the,
than the,
than the more concrete reality.
And you take a work of fiction
like hamlet and you think,
well is that it's,
it's not true because it's fiction.
But then you think,
wait a minute,
what kind of explanation is that?
Like maybe it's more true than nonfiction
because it takes what the story that
needs to be told about you and the story
that needs to be told about you and you
and you and you and abstracts that out.
And says,
look,
here's something that's a key part
of the human experience as such,
right,
so it's,
it's an abstraction from this underlying
noisy substrate and people are affected
by it because they see that the thing
that's represented as part of the pattern
of their being,
that's the right way to think about it.
And then with these old stories,
these ancient stories,
it seems to me like that process has
been occurring for thousands of years.
It's like we watched ourselves
and we extracted out some stories,
we imitated each other and we represented
that in drama and then we distilled
the drama and we got a representation
of the distillation and then we did it
again at the end of that process
that took God only knows how long.
I think some of these stories,
they've traced fairytales
back 10,000 years,
some fairy tales in
relatively unchanged for him.
And it certainly seems to me that the
archeological evidence for example,
suggests that the really
old stories that that,
that the Bible begins with our,
at least that old and likely embedded
in a prehistory that's far older than
that.
And you might think,
well,
how can you be so sure?
The answer to that in part is
that cultures that don't change,
like the ancient cultures,
right?
They didn't change as fast
as they stayed the same.
That's the answer.
So they call it,
they keep their information
moving generation to generation.
That's how they stay the same.
And so we know,
again in the archaeological record,
there are records of rituals that have
remained relatively unbroken for up to
20,000 years.
It was discovered in caves in Japan that
were set up for a particular kind of
bare worship that was also
characteristic of western Europe.
So these things can last for
very long periods of time.
We're watching each
other act in the world.
And then the question is,
well,
how long have we been watching each other?
And the answered that in some senses,
while as long as there's been creatures
with nervous systems and that's a long
time,
you know,
that's some hundreds of millions of years,
perhaps longer than that.
We'd been watching each other trying to
figure out what we're up to across that
entire span of time.
Some of that knowledge is
built right into our bodies,
which is why we can dance with each other,
for example.
Right?
Because understanding isn't
just something that you,
that you have as an abstraction.
It's something that you act out.
You know,
that's what children are
doing when they're learning
to rough and tumble plays.
They're learning to integrate their
body with the body of someone else in a
harmonious way,
learning to cooperate and compete,
and that's all instantiated
right into their body.
It's not abstract knowledge.
They don't know that they're doing that.
They're just doing it.
And so we can even use our body
as a representational platform.
So we've been studying
each other for a long time.
Abstracting out what is it that
we're up to and that's that.
That's what is it we're up to,
what should we be up to?
That's even a more fundamental question.
If you're going to live in the world
and you're going to do it properly,
what does properly mean and how is
it that you might go about that?
Well,
it's the right question,
right?
It's what everyone wants to know.
How do you live in the world?
Not what is the world made of.
It's not the same question.
How do you live in the world?
It's the eternal question of human
beings and I guess we're the only species
that has ever really asked that
question because all the other animals,
they just go and do whatever they do,
not us.
It's a question for us.
We've had to,
we have to become aware of it.
We have to be able to speak it.
God only knows why,
but that seems to be the situation.
So
we act that acting is shaped by the world,
that acting is shaped by society into
something that we don't understand,
but that we can model that.
We can model it.
We model it in our stories,
we Marlett with our bodies and that's
where the dream gets its information.
The dream is part of the process that's
watching everything and then trying to
formulate it and trying to say,
well,
trying to get the signal from the
noise and to portrayed in dramatic form
because the dream is little drama.
And then you get the chairs to s park
about what that dream is and then you have
it.
You have something like articulated
knowledge at that point.
And so the Bible I would say is,
is it sort of,
it exists in that space that's half
into the dream and half into articulated
knowledge.
It's something like that.
And going into it to find out
what the stories are about Ken,
what can it can aid
our self understanding.
And then the other issue is,
is that if nene,
she was correct and if Dostoevsky or
young was correct and Dostoevsky as well
without the cornerstone that
that understanding provides,
we're lost.
And that's not good because then
we're susceptible to psych pathology.
That's psychological pathology.
You know,
the people who are ad adamant,
anti religious thinkers seem to believe
that if we abandoned our immersement in
the underlying dream,
that we'd all instantly
become rationalists like
Descartes or bacon or you know,
intelligent,
clear thinking,
rational scientific people.
I don't believe that for a moment because
I don't think there's any evidence for
it.
I think we would become so irrational so
rapidly that the weirdest mysteries of
Catholicism would see
positively rational by contrast,
and I think that's already happening.